we need to
talk what's what did I come here just
just just
just what are you doing don't you know
what I'm doing yeah but you could tell
me what are what is that why are you why
are we going in the bathroom I thought
this is where you liked your privacy
shut up what is got into you no no no no
what come on let's go back to the party
come on wait we're missing everything
don't take that stop it stop it Jan no
no no no means Please don't slam against
the wall right here I'm not going to
slam you against anything you're acting
inappropriate J I'm acting inappropri
forget get out of my
way what um what do you think of role
play oh it can be fun yeah well Jan has
this school girl fantasy it's a pretty
common one I just I feel uncomfortable
wearing the dress Michael you shouldn't
do anything that you're uncomfortable
with Jan says anything that doesn't
scare us is not worth
doing I don't know maybe we're different
people I like cuddling and spooning and
she likes videotaping of saring sex oh
my god oh and then watching it back
right afterward to improve my form that
is not healthy Behavior no it's not that
bad the worst part is that she shows it
to her therapist and they discuss it
exactly I thought you said that you were
going to tidy things up well I shame on
you after you
ended everything with us I went on a
vacation to kind of clear my mind sounds
good sounds fun it was yeah it was
good I think I should just get right to
the point you know um I I I feel good
about myself for the first time in a
really long time and I've made some big
changes in my life
and I miss
you I want us to go back
together do you excuse me for a second
oh Defcon 20
she wants to get back together what are
you going to do I don't know that's why
you're here help me you want to get back
together with her no no what do I do
just don't get back together with her
what if she makes to me how can she make
you get back together with her she made
me do a lot of things I didn't want to
do this was a terrible relationship you
were not happy when you were with her I
wasn't you're so much happier now just
go in there and be strong you're right
you absolutely right I need to go in
there and tell her that we can't be
together
right wow do it I'm in a very good place
right now thank
you okay
Jan we need to
talk Jan is in a different place right
now and it is a sign of maturity
to give people Second
Chances so I'm going to hear her
out oh my
God yeah big actually that's
[Music]
crazy
so there are a lot of things I would
like to do differently yeah I feel like
when we first got together that I had a
problem with my priorities first got
priorities and if we could talk about a
a way to approach a possible
reconciliation let's get back
together no no no no no I'll tell you
this it is not because of the boob job
excuse me boob enhancement that would be
shallow and this is the opposite of
shallow this is emotionally
magnificent for example Jan and I have a
safe word in case things go too far
foliage and if one of us says that word
the other one has to
stop although last
time she pretended she didn't hear me
hello you Michel hey Buttercup I am on
my way should be there in about 15 let
just blow this party off that's what she
said yeah am I on speaker phone I yes
you are is anybody else hell J hi Dwight
okay Michael take me off speaker phone
no
problem okay let's just go to a motel
and just like rip into each other like
we did on the black sand beach in
Jamaica okay Jan Jan this party is
actually a very big step for us so I on
speaker um I I I don't know the camera's
there
maybe see you soon okay talk to you
later J all right bye Michael come over
after work tonight okay I miss your
body I don't know I feel I drive a lot
I'm spending a fortune on gas and I'll
give you $200 and if I get up before you
I'll leave it on the dresser um that I
don't know that makes me kind of
uncomfortable
300 I well I don't know whatever just
let my assistant know if you're coming
over so he can get more vodka okay
Hunter are you on you got it
CH babe yeah how about we take the beer
sign down until our guests leave and
then we can disc discuss it no no I'm
going to leave it up I think it ties the
whole room
together
okay Jen thinks Hunter's very talented
you know what I don't think he's that
good at least he's an artist BFD I'm a
screenwriter and I'm a Candle Maker but
you don't hear me bragging about it no
all you do is you get me to try to
worked on my rich friends for an
investment opportunity man I would love
to burn your candles you burn it you buy
it oh good I'll be your first customer
but you're hardly my
[Music]
first that is a $200 plasma screen TV
you just killed good luck paying me back
on your $0 a year salary plus benefits
babe you son of a
Jen this isn't the time of
interview where the hell do you get
off frankly it's overdue your behavior
in the last 2 years has been completely
erratic erratic recently you don't even
show an interest in your work you smoke
constantly in your office you spend most
of the day online shopping you disappear
for hours at a time sometimes days
always saying you're visiting your
sister in Scottdale you go to Scranton
far more often than you need is it
because of these whoa hey whoa J I want
to know I want to know because if it is
then then then I will see you in court
Jan told me to play at cool and not tell
anybody because it could get us both in
trouble so
officially I did not see
her but I did see Jen there in our
room at
night and in the morning that's all I'm
going to
say
sex we had
sex I had sex with
her I had sex with Chan hey dude just
got back from Jamaica big whoop I was in
hotlanta that whole town is waxed yeah
that sounds amazing but you know what
the lady Jan levenson wanted to go to
Montego Bay you took the ice cream I
don't buy it well I'm looking at a photo
right now and I'm telling you could be
in Maxum they wouldn't give you a
subscription to Maxum oh no no okay
well check this
out I'm sending you some
email you got it no I got
nothing check it again hit
refresh yeah Mike still nothing okay
wait a second I sent it to
you at Packer dundermifflin.com
packaging dundermifflin.com
uhoh wait I just got it from somebody
else what wow this is hot damn how do I
get you out of this picture hey J hello
baby how are you good to see you who's
your daddy you don't know who your daddy
is do you get us plastic
boobs